great great to be here how you guys
doing good well
as you may have noticed we live in a
culture a country that has entirely lost
its mind
I thought I'd start with the good news
we are living through a period of mass
psychosis that is very truly
unprecedented in the history of human
civilization
most speakers start with jokes and
things but I just dive right into it
Let's see we don't have a lot of time
let's just get to the get to the news
here
it seems as though all at once millions
of our countrymen woke up one day having
forgot some of the most basic facts
about reality like a giant epidemic of
the weirdest sort of amnesia and lying
at the heart of this intellectual chaos
is the confusion or the apparent
confusion anyway about identity
human biology gender a mental disease
called gender ideology has gripped hold
of a large swath of the American public
totally taken over our public
institutions the Disciples of this cult
have been convinced or pretend to have
been convinced that men are women and
women are men that men can have babies
and women can have penises that a woman
can impregnate a man who can then give
birth to it to and breastfeed a
genderless child
that somehow the most basic facts of
reality and of biology facts which all
people everywhere across the world for
thousands and thousands of years all
recognize intuitively are no longer
valid
it is total Madness and it is a Madness
that has infected our society and is now
threatening to tear it apart at the
seams I believe
and it's for this reason that we decided
that we had to make our film last year
called what is a woman as mentioned
introduction Which documents my
year-long effort to confront and expose
gender ideology our goal broadly was to
explore gender ideology to show it for
what it is but as the title suggests
this larger goal centered around one
seemingly quite simple and specific
question which is what is a woman
now backing up a few years it occurred
to me sometime shortly after Bruce
Jenner became Caitlyn and was
immediately declared woman of the year
and then eventually became a
conservative commentator on Fox News
lots of strange transitions happening in
this person's life
anyway when that first happened it it
became apparent to me that the word
woman ceases to have any meaning if a
guy named Bruce can be considered one
the word man too is emptied of meaning
it occurred to me also this is a major
problem for the left for people
promoting this agenda because if the
word woman no longer means adult human
female then what exactly does it
actually mean and if the left cannot
tell us what it means then how can they
use the word and if they can't use the
word then how can they do things like
have women's marches and talk about
women's rights or say anything about
women at all indeed how can a man say I
identify as a woman if the word woman
doesn't mean anything it's about as
meaningful as saying I identify as a
flipper doodle or a who's he wants it
how can anyone identify as gibberish and
if they do how are we supposed to affirm
and respect gibberish
I could not affirm gibberish even if I
wanted to and I don't want to and I
won't
so it became obvious to me that this
question what is a woman presents an
insurmountable logical problem for the
left and so I kept asking the question
and asking it and asking it and in every
Forum available to me which was mostly
just Twitter
and they simply ignored the question to
the extent that they could and They
carried on pretending like their
worldview was not fatally incoherent and
self-contradictory and after years of
this game of them ducking and dodging
the question I finally decided that it
was time to take this query to them to
put it in front of their faces confront
them with it directly
confront them with the incoherence of
their beliefs
and so began a quest that took us all
over the country even halfway around the
world to Kenya and to some other regions
of the third world like Los Angeles
and
we spoke to alleged experts you know
doctors therapists professors surgeons
we spoke to trans people themselves we
spoke to uh activists we spoke to
politicians we spoke to average people
on the street
we spoke to a naked guy walking down the
street in San Francisco
because they literally walk around naked
and that's it I don't know if you knew
that
it was news to me
you spoke to politicians we spoke to
average uh you know we spoke to nomadic
tribesmen living in Huts made out of cow
dung we spoke to everybody who would
speak to us
surprisingly only once did I have to use
a bullhorn during this whole time
and I learned quite a bit through this
extraordinary and often bewildering and
disturbing Adventure some of what I
learned came as a revelation
other lessons I think simply emphasized
and Illustrated what I already knew
but in either case it was enlightening
uh for me
and
it was a time you know fully immersed in
the most vile and toxic lunacy that the
world has ever known
at the end of it all we return back to a
truth that I of course already knew
before we started
that your biological identity is innate
it is determined for you before you are
born
this is a decision that was made by
powers
more powerful than any one of us
individually
you're either man or woman you don't get
to choose which category you belong to
you don't get to switch from one
category to another
your category does not depend on your
acceptance of it or agreement with it
so you could say oh I don't
I don't feel like I am that I don't want
to be that
but that is actually practically
speaking irrelevant
your self-perception May conflict with
yourself reality with your uh you know
your ideas about yourself but the former
cannot change the latter it is possible
for a person to perceive themselves to
be something that they are not so I
might perceive myself to be Oprah
yet no matter how sincerely I perceive
myself as Oprah no matter how upset I
would be to find out that I am not Oprah
I still am not Oprah I can change my
name to Oprah I can wear a costume to
look like Oprah
well actually I couldn't do that that'd
be blackface and they wouldn't that's
not allowed
that's the one kind of uh of
appropriation that's still not allowed
somehow
but I cannot be Oprah I cannot be
something that fundamentally contradicts
the identity I was born with I am stuck
with my fundamental identity whether I
like it or not in fact
I had a self that is you know what is a
self a self is a it's a person a being
I had a self long before I developed any
perceptions about myself
the self predates my perceptions of it
I was born as an infant with very little
self-awareness and yet I was still a
self I was still a person an identity
the self-perceived self-perception which
means that the self cannot be
fundamentally determined by
self-perception
our job is to bring our self-perception
into line with the reality of ourselves
just like it is our job to bring our
perception of the outside reality in
into line with what that reality
actually is
and if the two are not in line with each
other then the perception should be
changed to fit the physical reality we
cannot change the physical reality to
fit the perception
and so all this means that your sex is
determined without your consent
it is a matter of nature a matter of
physical reality and that physical
reality will either make you male or
female there are no other categories
those are the only ones nobody can
transcend this binary Arrangement nobody
can truly be trans
transgender is a category error it
doesn't actually exist
so there are people who say that they
are trans and I'd self-identify as trans
and use the term trans but they actually
aren't trans transgender people don't
exist as a category that's not possible
to be that
this is what makes gender ideology the
belief that gender is fluid that we can
choose to identify as a man or a woman
that men can have babies and women can
have penises and the rest of it this is
what makes the whole ideology insane and
poisonous and destructive
and that is also why I oppose gender
ideology ideology I oppose it
fundamentally because it is not true
there are a lot of other reasons to
oppose it
and people often talk about
conservatives often talk about uh the
effect that it has on children the
effect that it has on women the effect
it has on women's sports and women's
opportunities and all of those things
are extremely important
but that is not the basic reason why I
oppose it I oppose it first and foremost
because it isn't true
and everything else follows through that
follows from that way why is it so
harmful for children
because it isn't true
if it was actually true that an 11 year
old boy could be a girl whatever that
means
then it would be true and it wouldn't be
harmful but it isn't true
and all of the harm and if it was
actually true that a man who identifies
as a woman actually is a woman it's not
harmful to allow him in the women's
bathroom because that's where he belongs
because he is a woman but he isn't
it isn't true
I oppose all things that are not true
especially those things that eat away at
the most basic and essential realities
of life
now what I'd like to do from here is um
briefly address the five primary
objections to uh everything I've said in
the position that I take and that many
of us probably take on this topic
because these are objections that you've
probably heard
and I think there are still uh plenty of
people that understand the reality of
this and are not proponents of gender
ideology and yet who will get tripped up
by some of these objections when they're
raised
so it'd be useful to go through them
the first objection is uh they say well
you know you talk about sex and gender
like they're the same thing but they're
not sex is biological but gender is a
person's understanding or feeling about
themselves
the answer no
I don't well that's it that's just the
answer okay moving on to number move on
to the next one
no
I mean in all seriousness that is an
appropriate answer to all of this stuff
is just no and
move on now
if I had to elaborate I would say that
you know I don't think that sex and
gender are the same
it is you as the gender ideologue who
has essentially collapsed the very sex
versus gender distinction that you
engineered
and that was engineer originally by the
the people who invented the stuff John
money Alfred Kinsey those guys
so there was a time perhaps when you
would have agreed that there is at least
a biological difference between a woman
who is female and a self-identified
woman who is male if we turn the clock
back 25 years
this same conversation was happening
much more out on the fringes but the
people who were proponents of it would
have most of them admitted that well you
know as a trans woman isn't biologically
a woman there's a difference
they don't admit that anymore
okay they say that trans women are women
they have erased this distinction
um if you did still affirm a
definitional distinction between sex and
gender then you would have to also
affirm that there is in this world a
binary category of male and female and
that those who belong to each category
cannot cross between the two but you
will not affirm any binary at all or any
subset distinction at all between
so-called trans women and women which
means that the whole gender versus sex
thing was nothing but a sleight of hand
trick it was a bait and switch
now as for me I have no use for the term
gender at all in fact we should all stop
using that term that would be the best
thing for us to do
gender doesn't exist as far as people
are concerned gender originally you know
it originates as a as a as a term that
applies to words to language words have
gender people have a sex
and once we established that there are
just men and women males and females we
don't need this concept of gender at all
now the response to that is well uh
yes but there's
men and women have different ways of
expressing themselves different ways of
interacting with the world different
ways of uh of living out their
identities and so on and so forth
well yes they do
we already have a word for that it's
called personality
that is personality
and so so much of what we see if you see
the purple-haired people on Tick Tock
that are talking about their 12
different gender identities and how it
changes by the second
what they're actually trying to describe
is their personality their their rather
fickle personalities
and but the concept of Personality has
been eaten by the concept of gender and
so that's how we end up in a situation
where you've got people who have you
know five different genders and seven
different sexual orientations but no
personality to speak of
because their personalities have been
consumed by all of these other labels